hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
and these days i've become increasingly
interested in the idea
of democracy uh democracy
we all know it most of us are in favor
of it if you took a poll most people
would say that democracy is a good idea
many people would say that it's under
threat there are people who are
working to undermine democracy people
might not agree on who those people are
okay
here at mindscape we're less interested
in the political
moment of our contemporary time and more
interested in
the underlying ideas that are used to
justify and to push forward or to pull
back
on an idea like democracy what is
democracy how does it work how should it
work
why is it such a good idea is it always
such a good idea
these are the kinds of things that i'm
interested in thinking about
so today we're going to be talking about
an aspect of democracy or an idea that
is
very closely intertwined with the idea
of democracy which is the
idea of free speech again if you ask
most people they would say yes
free speech i am in favor of that it's
when the rubber hits the road and when
you're getting into individual specific
examples that it becomes harder
and actually i think it should become
harder this is one of the things that i
would personally want to emphasize here
is that
the way to go wrong talking and thinking
about free speech is to pretend that
it's easy
to pretend that it's absolute and
there's a clearly right way to think
about it in a clearly wrong way to think
about it
think about the following two extreme
examples extreme versions
of free speech even if you admit that
free speech is good
what do you mean by that so one version
might be
everyone has the freedom to say whatever
they want
but literally nobody else will ever hear
them
so that's a kind of free speech you can
say whatever you want right but if
nobody hears you what is the point
that's really not quite maybe enough
whereas on the other side you might say
okay
to me free speech means not only can you
say whatever you want
but everyone has to hear what you say
and then worse than that everyone has to
agree with me
that's a very extreme form of free
speech that probably also
nobody would go along with and what we
want is somewhere in the middle
but where in the middle and both these
examples drive home the importance of
not only thinking about the person
speaking but of the audience the people
being spoken to
and that's why i really like the kind of
analysis provided by today's guest
teresa beijan who is a political
theorist at the university of oxford
in the uk and someone who's thought
deeply about free speech
also in a historical context not only as
a political theorist
so what she points out is that the
traditional if you go all the way back
to ancient athens
there were different greek words
corresponding to different
notions of free speech there was a
notion of isagoria which is the right of
citizens to participate in public debate
which was much more public facing than
this different notion of parisia which
was a
license to say what you please to be
frank to speak your mind
to be politically incorrect if you want
to put it that way and we
translate both of these the same way
which leads us to confusion sometimes
when we think about what free speech
should be
and then she traces it through history
and points out the importance
in the united states especially at the
very interesting case of the early
founding of rhode island
which was as she points out one of the
most open tolerant societies in the
world at the time
uh on the importance of civility in the
sense of
i should listen to you not civility in
the sense that when i
say bad things about you i should say
them in polite terms but
i actually have an obligation as a
listener to listen to you and that's a
really high bar when it comes to free
speech so
we're not going to answer once and for
all in any clear-cut way that everyone
will agree with
all of the uh questions you might raise
about free speech but
i think that listening to this podcast
listening to uh teresa's explanations of
these issues
gives us a richer feeling for how we
should think
about these issues because they're
important issues it's not enough
just to say yes democracy free speech
good we have to be
both clear on what we mean and we have
to be able to defend
why our particular point of view is the
right way to think about these
very very contentious issues so with
that let's go
[Music]
theresa bichon welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks for having me
i need to start with a sort of um ironic
observation here
because on the one hand uh you have
pointed out
things like the importance when it comes
to free speech of not only letting
people talk but also
listening to them right actually taking
into account what they're saying with
some kind of an open mind but at the
same time
in our modern world the phrase free
speech has kind of become
a flashpoint and a little marker for
where you land in certain culture war
disputes so i'm sure that a lot of
listeners when they tune into this
podcast
are going to be first thinking like what
side is she on is she on the right one
or the wrong one and then listen to you
or discard you uh on the basis of that
without listening very carefully have
you have you come across this phenomenon
absolutely uh in an indeed that
phenomenon is one of the reasons why i'm
so interested
in free speech debates today but also
about some of the other things we'll
talk about
civility and equality i think that um
discussions
both in the academy and in the public
sphere about all of these topics
are becoming increasingly politicized
and so
maybe my driving reason for being at
this point is trying to say that no we
can talk about them in a way
that doesn't just reduce to determining
you know which side am i on and is it
the right one
all right well now that we know what
side you're on people can decide whether
they should listen what's funny i mean
with the free speech issue
um you're absolutely right that it has
become politicized and
that um in particularly in the present
debate there's this sense that okay well
free speech as a principle is being
weaponized or is being sort of colonized
by the right
um and therefore when someone is
pleading for the importance of free
speech
there that's a sort of dog whistle that
they're kind of you know
sort of coming from the right wing um
but it's just worth noting
noticing just how you know that it's a
kind of polar
reversal from how things have been in
recent history in the united
ideal of the states i mean the whole
free speech movement got its start at
berkeley
um the idea that suddenly it's the right
wing that cares about free speech is
is pretty historically curious so
another thing that i i think is
important is to take a sufficiently
long view that we can at least you know
for our own minds you know just see that
there's no
natural connection between these
principles and one or other side of the
political
uh spectrum that there's a kind of
contingency here and we should be able
to think about what these ideals mean
and um what they look like in practice
apart from
their kind of contingent um
politicization in the present moment
the other thing that you know speaking
of which i suppose i should say
uh in reading some of your stuff i was
really struck by the connection between
free speech and democracy i mean i guess
obviously we think of democracy as
something that goes hand in hand with
free speech but
it seemed that there was a more
fundamental uh underlying
commonality of idea there that the idea
that
people have the right to self-govern
is inextricably wound up with the idea
that people have a voice and the right
to talk is that
is that a correct uh interpolation or am
i just seeing things there
that's right um and it's something
that's very much on my mind i
you know today we're very concerned with
this idea of
voice and finding a voice making it
possible for those who have been
traditionally excluded to have a voice
and that kind of concern i think
is really ancient and connected with
with this intuition that democratic
government is
is the regime that most
um uh is best at
ensuring a voice to all
those governed um and so thinking about
democracy is a matter
not just of voting which is you know
that tends to be the limited sense in
which we think of a public voice today
i have a voice in so far as i'm able to
vote um
for my representative but also thinking
of democracy as
about um talk and having a say
in in just the more sort of quotidian
way of just being able to you know
get my voice heard yeah i mean it it
immediately
i guess what what struck me about it was
how it prefigures this idea
that speech is a form of power right
that speech is not just something that
floats
out there in the air separate from the
the levers of power in our society that
who speaks who gets listened to
etc is part of that complex absolutely
um i mean it's funny a lot of times uh
in talking about free speech especially
for those coming from the more kind of
civil libertarian
uh side who are really committed to
individual rights to free speech
often those you know free speech
fundamentalists if you will
are accused of being indifferent to
power but i think that sort of that
misses the mark i think that civil
libertarians are are really
sensitive to power dynamics and the
power of voice
um and are worried about granting
a kind of arbitrary power to you know
the powers that happen to be to decide
who speaks and who doesn't
um so i think that right that original
sort of democratic sense
of of the importance and power of voice
is connected i mean if we just look at
ancient greek democracy
democracy in greek it just comes from
the idea of
deimos kratos so people power right it's
so in a democracy
it's the deimos that is empowered to
speak it's the people
and then you can look at different
institutional arrangements that try to
make that you know try to make it
possible for the people to speak
um but i think that you know for all
democracies ancient modern that's what
we're trying to do we're trying to find
a way
of allowing the people to speak in a way
that is as equal as possible
yeah to sort of distribute that power
equally i i guess the thing is
is constantly going on in the back of
people's minds when you say like what do
you say makes perfect sense probably
most people
if you ask them should you let the
people speak etc they'd be all for that
but
everyone has in the back of their minds
some particular group
that they want to be able to speak right
and and
uh applying that universally is a
challenge
i i just don't think the human mind is
really programmed
to yeah and to be able to apply our
values universally i
mean you know it's a highly
controversial thing to say many of my
colleagues in moral and political
philosophy will be very annoyed with me
for saying it but
i do just think we're not really built
to be able to
um reason uh sort of
uh in a principled way all the time
which is why
we you know try to cultivate and build
institutions that can kind of relieve
some of that pressure
and i think broadly speaking what we
think of as liberal rights
uh individual rights um are precisely
developed in order to sort of alleviate
that pressure
to sort of save us the trouble of trying
to act in a principled way all the time
sort of
you know to do that kind of judging for
us but you said i mean you framed it
positively you said we usually have a
sense of the group we want particularly
to hear or they think
needs a voice i would actually be
inclined to frame it negatively i think
most of the time people are clearest on
who or you know the individuals or
groups they think
should not have a voice um
and you know i think you know pick your
pick your um
bet noir here i mean fascists racists
social justice warriors the woke etc
we have an idea of you know the group
that needs the volume
turned down on them well but but
empirically and we don't uh
we don't talk that way right i mean we
don't go actively uh
we broadly speaking uh it's not
the accepted thing to say we should shut
these people up
so much sometimes that happens but the
the positive case is sort of the more
compelling one no
am i making that up oh i think a lot
rests on we
bear sort of who are we and who are we
speaking of
i mean i think you're right i think that
for the most part um people
are when they are concerned negatively
about
um the groups that they see as a kind of
danger to
principles of equality or or equal
liberty and society
they're concerned in good faith yeah but
i i mean i found this in my work on
civility as well it's just our i think
our
brains tend to focus better on
the source of threat right okay rather
than a kind of you know positive ideal
um but you know we can we can come to
that
you mentioned the ancient greeks and i
didn't want to zip over them too quickly
i was really fascinated by this
distinction
uh that you mentioned between two
different kinds of free speech that the
greeks pinpointed so why don't you share
that with us
it's my dearest wish as an academic to
be
able to write articles for
uh popular audiences that
um hinge on making a distinction in
ancient greek
you've come to the right podcast anyway
that i have that i have been able to do
this so i
so um in ancient greek there's a
distinction between um
horacia on the one hand and isagoria
on the other and these are both um
ideas and practices associated with
democratic athens in particular so
poracia is the idea of free
speech in the sense of speaking freely
we might think of a frank speech
speaking frankly um
and it's precisely the idea that you
know you speak your mind
without fear or favor whenever
wherever and and to whomever you choose
um
but isiguria is more closely connected
with
the democratic institutions as they
existed in athens and it's an idea of
the
equal right of citizens
to address the public assembly
so what partly what interests me
is precisely this the process by which
what was a clear distinction in ancient
greek and also i would argue
in um in um later centuries and sort of
the reception of the greek
uh tradition about thinking about
freedom and democracy
that distinction has just been lost in
modern
um in in modern english and in modern
times and so what you'll find now in a
lot of the greek sources that i that i
use
is that where the greek distinguishes
paris between
uh parisia and uh and isagria
um in english they're just both
translated as free speech
so the distinction is erased um in the
act of translation
and so partly what i'm trying to do is
to recover this distinction and to show
that actually it helps make sense of
some of the more fraught kind of culture
war style debates we're having about
free speech today
we're actually just there are two
different principles at stake and it and
it behooves us
to um wrap our heads around them is
parisian supposed to be
construed as something more personal or
interpersonal somehow
like i can say things that you might
find insulting and
i got i have the right to do that
whereas is igoria
is more political or am i
putting things down i think it's no i
think that that's
right i would just um i would make two
slight corrections so i think
it's not quite right to discuss to
discuss bracia
in terms of a right um what's really
important in in
this concept and especially um in the
centuries after
classical athens is the idea that parisi
is really seen as is
a license as a kind of privilege
and um it's a license granted by the
powerful to the weak
i allow you to speak your mind
okay to me so i i say well i will
tolerate your free and frank speech
um and you know this this comes into uh
manuals on rhetoric talking about the
figure of lycentia or license the idea
that um a speaker might claim a license
to say something that the audience may
not want to hear so um
i think actually it's in the modern um
and i would say you sort of post first
amendment renderings of parisia that
we get this idea that you could have a
right to speak freely and frankly
um but you're absolutely right that it's
isigria is really closely connected with
political institutions and specifically
democratic institutions
isagria is a right that is ensured
equally
to those who belong as members
to the deimos and then who can then who
can then
attend and participate in debate
in the public forum um so it's not you
you know it doesn't really make sense to
discuss isagria um
outside of or in the absence of those
democratic institutions
as we exercise our minds in new and
interesting ways remember that it's also
important to exercise our bodies
and if you're like me the important
thing about exercising is that
you need some structure to motivate
yourself but you also need the
flexibility to do it when
you can for those reasons peloton is an
ideal solution
i've tried out the peloton bike and it's
a wonderful way to be creative with
workouts while still being motivated
by someone telling you that you can do
even more you can keep going and you can
try harder
and with the new peloton bike plus there
are new features that empower you to
seamlessly add strength training to the
routine
you can see things from a new angle with
a larger screen that easily rotates
you can increase the challenge level by
changing the resistance with a quick
touch
rather than turning a knob and you can
hear the peloton instructors
loud and clear with an immersive high
fidelity sound system
and now new members get to try it for
themselves with a 30-day home trial you
can experience everything the new
peloton
bike plus has to offer for 30 days and
if you're not interested
you get a free pickup and a full refund
visit onepeloton.com for more
information that's
o n e o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
so how does something like um the
debates over
whether hate speech should be allowed or
or
censored or illegal fit into this is is
the
is the side that says well i should be
able to say what i want even if it's
hateful
is that a uh appeal to parisia
yeah i so i would classify it this way
so you have
sort of modern parisiasty if you will
sort of modern proponents of of free and
frank speech
um arguing a kind of uh
it was also often described as free
speech absolutism but i actually think
that that's
not not really accurate uh an accurate
description of you but what i would call
a kind of free speech fundamentalism
that gives priority always
to the right of individuals to speak
their minds um
no matter how offensive yeah that
happens to be to the audience
um but then on the other side you have
people who are really really worried
about the ways in which
exercises of parisia can um
not just harm um
others but cause a specific kind of harm
which is a kind of dignitary harm the
idea that hate speech
in this example is a kind of assault on
the equal status or standing
of members of racial gender
ethnic minorities and thus
thus th the argument would come back and
so i would say the modern defender of
isagaria
is more worried about how we secure and
um maintain this this system of kind of
equal speakers
and on that view you might then say well
parisian needs to be restricted
so that isa korea can be protected right
okay
yeah i mean there's um this famous
cartoon that flies around the internet
about karl popper's paradox of tolerance
have you seen this
i sure have i'm sure people are going to
bring it up right so that's why i'm
pre-empting them but
the idea being that you think that you
want to be tolerant of everybody but
some people are intrinsically intolerant
and tolerating them
can be the the death of tolerance and
therefore we should only tolerate some
people
i just i i just i have to i'm so pleased
you brought it up so that i can um
so i can complain about it please really
so again i will come to this later later
in the discussion
um uh because i i talk about this
directly in my work on civility and
tolerance
um but i i think it's really um
it makes a pretty important mistake
about what tolerance
is and what it means it's precisely
the putting up with something we
acknowledge to be an evil
yeah um and in my view a tolerant
society that as a matter of principle
doesn't tolerate the intolerant is not a
tolerant society
um you know i think we can make we can
have arguments about what we might call
militant democracy the idea that in
democracies
there should not be any right to
organize
as an anti-democratic party right so
that we
so you don't have a case where um you
know the nazis run on a platform of
abolishing parliamentary election
elections and then are elected right so
that kind of case
um so i think that you can make sense
conceptually of militant democracy
i don't think that um militant tolerance
actually makes any sense and um i think
that the idea is sort of traceable i
mean forget popper you can trace it to
herbert marcuza
and the idea of repressive tolerance
right the idea that we have to
repress the enemies of tolerance and um
i just i i don't i know people really
enjoy sharing that
you know that that cartoon they think
it's a sort of knock down argument but i
would just sort of beg them
to think a little bit more deeply about
what that actually means i mean i think
in my
you know my in my book i talk about you
know a tolerant society cannot pick and
choose its materials and remain tolerant
for long
um and yeah i would just that that's my
view but i think you're right
it's the same idea um in uh
debates today about free speech the idea
that some speech needs to be silenced
so as to protect the principle of free
speech
for all right or you know for you know
to make the the make the right to free
speech equal
yeah i mean we have to get into that
obviously because that is it is a tricky
one and drawing the boundaries between
speech that should be allowed in speech
i mean there's some speech there's
shouting
fire in a crowded theater right which is
the classic example of
something that you're not allowed to do
so there's a more general principle
there but
again when i brought up the hate speech
example
um that's sort of the free speech
um sloganeering that goes on on one's
eye that you know i should be able to
say hateful things as long as you're not
physically harmed but then
there's the other side to map it back
onto the isagoria parisia uh
distinction there's there's a concern
about free speech it says well look you
know i have a point of view
and my point of view is just not being
represented
in the discourse right like you know
certain kinds of ideas are just not
mentioned on tv
it's just not considered respectable etc
so shouldn't i have a right to be
heard in some way i
i think that way of framing it is
exactly right i think very often what
the the sense of um righteous
indignation
that's fueling a lot of this culture war
and i would say that actually on both
sides you have people who feel
sincerely and righteously indignant that
their views
cannot get a hearing um and
i i i i have a paper in which i make
some of these argue
make the argument sort of more
technically but i think the basic thrust
is this
i i don't think that you can
have an equal enforceable right to be
heard
i just don't i think that's a
non-starter on
the level of society as such i think
that you can have that kind of right to
a
hearing in well-defined
relatively small scale deliberatory fora
like the democratic assembly in athens
like a faculty meeting like the
um you know the parliamentary chamber or
the
or the the senate floor right when you
have a well-defined
space of debate you can say
okay everybody gets gets a hearing
um and so i think that the the impulse
though to say well that
has to be realized on the scale of
society as such
in order for free speech to be sort of
meaningful
um i understand the impulse but i just
think that it
it can't actually work
um on the scale of society and therefore
the costs of trying to realize it um
are unacceptable from the point of view
of
of freedom of speech that sounds
reasonable to me but i'm i i'm
i hear the worry that
uh you know this makes free speech
let's put it dramatically into a tool of
oppression into a tool of maintaining
the status quo because you say well
everyone should be able to speak some
people have access
to microphones and amplification and
some people don't so
you're baking in some kind of inequality
from the start um
yeah i'm very sensitive to that response
and i think
that it's absolutely right to point out
the status quo bias
in a lot of um liberal defenses of
individual rights
um so i'm not indifferent to power in
this case i suppose that
my my my sense always is though you know
um
in in such arguments you're effectively
calling for the suppression
and exclusion of hateful
um or um denigrating views right and
it's just but
i mean who are you proposing to have
that power to censor
and it's always going to be the powers
that be right
and there's just this faith it's a very
strange faith
on the one hand that our governors are
incompetent evil etc but on the other
hand that we should empower them even
further
to suppress views they don't like
um and so i guess that that is why i
you know again if your listeners are
trying to work out what side i i'm on i
mean it's it's the small
c small l civil libertarian side that
simply says
look um absolutely free
the principle of free speech can be
weaponized by those who
want to just cling very very tightly to
their right to
insult other people on the basis of
descriptive characteristics
um that yes that can and does happen
but that itself doesn't disqualify or
somehow
you know render invalid the importance
of free speech
and that in itself is not an argument
for why
a system wherein we don't value
parisia at all would be
better yeah from the perspective of the
things we claim to care about namely
equality and
and the rest i mean i think that there's
good historical evidence to then say
well we should be skeptical of the idea
that an
alternative system would actually be
better for the marginalized
um but i agree with you i mean it's it's
it's
it's a it's an important worry and i
worry it's a and my concern is that it's
a worry that's not necessarily taken
seriously by a lot of those who um you
know identify
as being on the kind of civil
libertarian side of the disagreement
yeah no i mean i
i take it as my role as the podcast host
to try to you know bring up the
imaginary
uh opponents of these things but i'm
essentially on your side here i mean i
think that
an argument oh no i've got to change my
mind now you know
what i'm worried about you didn't know
what i was on i tricked you um
no i mean i think that there's a very
sensible argument to be made that
sure if you say on the one hand everyone
has the right to talk and on the other
hand
some people have microphones and some
don't uh that's an unequal balance there
but nevertheless
we have to maintain that kind of uh
equality of right to talk because
eventually that that will be a tool for
the people who don't have power like if
you take that away from them then what
is the hope
yeah i i just i i would i would again
and this is you know
i'm i'm a political theorist and a
political philosopher but i really do
come to it from the history of political
thought and just thinking about these
these political questions historically
and
you know the defenders of the right to
censor suppress and exclude
are often themselves part of or see
themselves as allies of the
establishment
and i guess one of the one of the
interesting things in in debates today
is that we're in this cultural moment
where there are kind of conflicting
establishments right we might think of
the
intellectual uh
academia media establishment
um as being ranged against the political
establishment to take the american case
and i think that that that maps well
onto the british case as well
um and that's a kind of unique
historical
moment but i but i mean i don't think
it's desirable for those for those
establishments
for those rival establishments and their
partisans to begin
just duking it out as a kind of power
conflict
opposed from the idea that there are
principles that should bind
um to bind how we how we um
conduct our disagreements yeah and one
of those principles being the principle
of free speech i mean in the uk now we
have this
sort of bizarre situation where the
government is now sort of
wanting to impose free speech quote
unquote on the university
and i just either figure again for
someone uh
broadly civil libertarian you know to me
that's not a desirable outcome it's very
similar
we have the same thing in the u.s it is
yeah i love your idea of the conflicting
establishments because it's very real
and it
it's a wonderful thing because everyone
can think of themselves as an oppressed
minority
right because there's some other
establishment that doesn't agree with
them
absolutely and i just my again
you know my other dearest wish um since
i'm just sharing my dearest wishes with
you sean
um my other dearest wishes that people
can just take seriously the feeling
of righteous indignation on all sides
not grants that all indignations are
equally righteous
but grants that everyone experiences
their indignation equally righteously
um and i because i i do very often think
what we really need to resist is this
polarization of every um
question of principle into are you or
are you not on the right side
um and again i think you know just kind
of approaching these questions from the
perspective of
say the 17th century and debates about
religious toleration
is really good training for identifying
and resisting the sectarian impulse
which i do think is just endemic and in
human um
psychology and human community we we
like to believe and belong on the basis
of our shared beliefs
um and that's the kind of you know
feature and bug
of how human beings work um and so
what we should be doing i think is you
know and i when i say we i mean
people like me who are lucky enough to
be in the academy lucky enough to be
educators
is sort of helping our students
cultivate the virtues that allow them to
resist
that pull yeah yeah okay good i mean and
i do
i think i i like the fact that you you
come at this from a historical angle and
i definitely want to get much more into
the history of rhode island than we've
ever gotten into before here
on mindscape but but maybe this is the
good place
since we're already into the
conversation i don't think that i've
let you given you the opportunity to
sort of in your eyes
what is the best justification for free
speech like what is the argument it's
become such a cliche like in the us and
the uk we
of course we're pro free speech largely
uh
uh construed but or broadly construed
but there
are different possible justifications
you could offer for that and they might
not be the same they might not be
equally appropriate i mean do you have a
favorite reason why we should be small c
small
civil libertarians in a sense it's a
great question and it's one that
i i managed not to confront for for
quite a long time
i knew that as as anyone who's ever been
a graduate student knows you spend most
of your time deciding who annoys you and
who whom you disagree with before you're
sort of in the business of
proffering your own positive argument
that doesn't go away when you're a much
more senior faculty member but uh
yeah it's definitely true um but i knew
that i
i didn't find the kind of million k so i
mean jon stewart million case for free
speech
persuasive the idea that free speech is
justified as a means to truth production
um and so i've been much more drawn
to historical justifications of
free speech that emphasize the um
the sanctity of individual conscience um
so
the idea is that all human beings have
minds um we have no choice but to make
up our minds for ourselves
although we try to you know free
ourselves of that responsibility as much
as possible
uh and that a system of free speech is
the one wherein
we respect the sort of you know
the fact that people equally have minds
um and i think you know i think one way
of thinking about it especially in this
kind of um
in the case of current debates is that
we're very concerned about the ways in
which certain voices can't be
heard on the basis of their identity
so right we're familiar with the ways in
which women's voices are discounted
racial minorities voices are discounted
now increasingly gender
um gender non-conforming identities are
discounted
but what i always come back to is you
know identities don't speak
individuals do my descriptive
characteristics don't determine what i'm
going to think or say
on any given issue and so we
any sort of uh political legal social
system surrounding speech i think has to
attend to and credit that fact um
and a society that values
that um or sort of you know respects
that individual
conscience for me is is one in which i'd
much prefer
to live and then again we get into the
negative case which is that because
in societies that don't we we sort of
empower
the powers that happen to be to censor
on our behalf
um but in that kind of case for free
speech i mean that's much closer to the
case that someone like
john milton would make okay um
and something you know in the 1640s than
it is to
the case that jon stewart mill would
make in in the 1840s um
that that case is is a is an older case
and it's um you know in the 17th century
was an explicitly kind of christian case
it was about the power of the word it
was about the
importance of conscience um but i think
it's
a lot more persuasive or sort of more
accurately or effectively captures the
kinds of things i care about
than do some of the more safely secular
arguments well i mean it sounds maybe my
understanding of the history of
philosophy is imperfect i know it is but
uh it sounds like a kind of kantian uh
conception rather than a more human
conception i mean
giving some um giving priority to the
autonomy of individuals
rather than just sort of like a more
let's try everything and see what works
kind of thing
i think that's fair again i you know i'm
just i'm sort of set in my um
my uh contrarian ways and i i
really don't like autonomy oh okay you
don't like autonomy i
i i i know what you were saying
perhaps i should be be clearer i i don't
think that the that um i don't believe
that persons are autonomous in the way
that kant described them i don't think
they are i don't think they can be
autonomous in the way that that kant
described them and that it's not the
power so for kant
the the justification for the um
as he would have put it the public use
of one's reason
is that we need you know we need the
the freedom to reason publicly in order
to
be rational um and
i i think that i see the attraction of
that sort of argument but i
i don't actually believe that
speech is fundamentally about exchanging
reasons
i think speech is about a whole lot more
than that it's about affect it's about
enthusiasm
it's about everything else and so the
kind of the the christian
privileging of the word if you will sort
of seeing the word as something that
is all powerful and exists kind of apart
from the individuals who receive or
speak it
um actually is closer to my view but i
understand you know
as i'm saying this you know again for
your listeners what side is she on it's
beginning to sound very very protestant
and the funny thing is of course that i
you know i i like these religious
arguments but i'm not myself religious
so no no i think that's that's wonderful
because our culture
went through that even for the most
secular of us today
right i mean the history definitely uh
engaged with that but i think
i think what you just said was very
helpful to me because now i
i'm seeing more of the distinction
you're trying to draw i mean
mill uh and you know his later
avatars i guess like habermas would
count i mean had this idea of
reasoning and talking to each other and
sharing ideas and that's why we couldn't
declare certain ideas out of bounds
because then we might miss some good
ones and you know
we're we're handicapping ourselves in
the search for the truth whereas
you're uh you're much more concerned
about it sounds like let me let me
phrase it and then you can correct me
it sounds like you're more concerned
about just the the idea that people
should have the right to spout off
and say what they want because they're
they're individuals and even if what
they say is nonsense
and it doesn't help us find the truth
they still would have the right to say
nonsense peddlers are people too yeah
exactly uh is my view
the intolerant are people too hypocrites
are people too i mean
and you know the point is that people
are people and people very often suck
yeah but it's empirical people who have
rights um
yeah i know i think that's a helpful way
of of putting it
and here again i just think a historical
perspective is crucial
um if we're interested in where our
you know quote unquote our modern
institutions our modern
commitments come from there is a really
important kind of divergence between the
way in which free speech principles and
institutions develop in the united
states and what will become the united
states so in north america and how they
develop in europe and the european
tradition as you say
we might say culminating in habermas the
european arguments are much more focused
on speech as a vehicle for reason
and argument um and you see this
reflected actually in the language in
which the demand is expressed so if we
think about
you know spinoza he's talking about the
freedom to philosophize
um kant himself is talking again about
the
the right to exercise one's reason in
public
mill talks about the liberty of thought
and discussion
so it's never about free speech as such
it's always about
this category of reasoned speech and so
there's quite a lot of uh
exclusion of a lot of speech um built
into that
whereas in the american case you know we
it's not philosophers
who are worried about this and sort of
building up institutions you know you
know except maybe for thomas jefferson
it's a bunch of evangelical christians
uh a lot of self-styled prophets and so
what they're worried about
is how to build an institutional system
that
protects the right to spread
the word so the freedom to proselytize
as opposed to the freedom to
philosophize
and i do think that this accounts um you
know not fully but to
to a large extent the very different
cultures around freedom of speech
and the greater tolerance for not only
pornography but prophecy
that you get in america as opposed to
other
liberal democracies probably life
insurance
isn't at the top of your list of
priorities right now but it's something
that you can do
it's easy to do with policygenius.com
and it will take a load off your mind so
you don't have to worry about it anymore
the good news is you can save over 1500
or more a year
by using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies from different
companies
when you're shopping for a policy that
could last a decade or more these
savings really start to add up
policy genius is an insurance
marketplace built and backed by a team
of industry experts
it's a very easy process step one you go
to policygenius.com
in minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and compare quotes
from top insurers
step two you apply for the lowest price
step three the policy genius team
handles all the paperwork and red tape
policy genius works for you
not for the insurance company they even
have policies that allow eligible
customers to skip the in-person medical
exam
and do it all over the phone so if you
need life insurance
head to policygenius.com right now to
get started you can
save money and feel comfortable that
you're making the right choice
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right
and the you make a wonderful case for
thinking more than we usually do in
american history about roger williams in
the case of rhode island
and uh the idea i mean he's a
fascinating character
which i i had heard his name before but
reading in your stuff about you know how
committed he was to his ideals and those
ideals led him to
create a space where people who he
thought were terrible
could nevertheless participate yeah um
you know i'm from i'm from north
carolina so we don't really get taught
anything about rhode island
in the american south um but i did i
just became really fascinated with him
um when i was in grad school and ended
up arguing in
in my first book that roger
roger williams um not only not only his
theory but
actually more importantly his practice
of civility and tolerance
was not only a good model for thinking
about civility
tolerance and speech in in society today
but also historically important in that
that sort of brand of protestant
evangelicalism
um helps explain american exceptionalism
when it comes to
freedom of speech and why our approach
to freedom of speech is more presiastic
if you will than um than that of other
uh
modern democracies and in particular
this this notion of civility is one that
you examine
closely i think that sort of casually a
lot of people are going to think
we have to be nice to each other and not
insult
each other but that's not what the
central point is for you
no um so in my work on civility
uh which is really i guess where all of
this began i i
was interested to to really work out
what
what distinguishes civility from other
conversational virtues
so as you say i think in common parlance
we tend to think oh well to be civil
means to be nice it means to be
respectful it means to be polite
but um if you think about it for a bit
you it very quickly
uh appears that that that can't that
can't be right because when we're
talking about civility
um we we
are talking about something that is um
well i mean i might say it has three
distinguishing features that you know
that
show it to be peculiar and not um not
reducible to those other virtues i mean
the first one is that civility seems to
be appropriate
to um disagreement in particular
so we talk about civility when we're
talking about how we should conduct our
disagreements
um secondly civility has a kind of
minimal character
so we can talk about being merely civil
um civility is what we need to deal with
um
bad neighbors ex-spouses members of the
other party
and so it has this kind of low but low
but solid
kind of sense that um other virtues like
um
decorum politeness respect don't um and
then thirdly and finally
civility comes from the latin
uh civilitas which in turn comes from
civitas which means um
political society or civil society and
so civility seems to
be a virtue that should pertain to
disagreements between those who stand in
a particular kind of relation i.e the
relation of
citizen or uh co-members of a single
civil society
and so it's sort of working through
those features of civility that led me
to to conclude that a lot of the debates
um uh going on at the time when i was
writing and publishing
my book and also now with the kind of
culture where free speech debates we've
been talking about
a lot of the debates that um claim to be
about you know free
those who support free speech versus
those who are against free speech
are actually debates about different
cultures of civility
intolerant societies so how much
uncivil talk or how much insults how
much kind of nastiness
can a tolerant society put up with
um and so it was in that it was in
trying to reframe debates about um
speech and tolerance in that way
that i then came to just uh
single out um roger williams offering a
particular model about how we might
think of civility in a tolerant society
as being consistent
with quite a lot of um free and frank
speaking speaking
but nevertheless um made it possible
for um a society of proselytized
proselytizers to
rub along together um despite their
differences
yeah so civility in this in this sense
is is not to be conflated with
politeness or decorum but more
i mean i want to put words in your mouth
but more just a willingness
to keep engaging despite the craziness
that these people are saying
yeah i mean so i think in the book i
define mere civility as
the uh as a minimal conformity to
culturally contingent
norms of respectful behavior so you'll
see i mean there is an idea as we abide
by or we conform ourselves to
norms of respectful behavior but not
because we actually respect
or um because you know not because we're
sort of sincerely committed to treating
others respectfully
and the distinction is important because
mere civility then becomes a way
not only of um not only is it consistent
with
actually feeling disrespect
for others but it can actually become a
way of communicating
disrespect or contempt for others so
when i treat you with mere civility sean
i mean i
that that that could be a way of of
conveying to you
exactly what i think right now you're in
your wrong views
yeah and so and i mean as you say
okay well fair enough right this is a
way of distinguishing it from respect
but sort of what does it really mean in
in the in the clutch and and i think
what you've singled out is exactly right
mere civility is this willingness
and commitment to engaging with our
opponents
um and to continuing to engage and share
a life
with those we don't respect
um i think you know if i've put it in
the past and i think this captures it
pretty well is the idea you know it
reflects our commitment to share a life
even when we don't share a faith um
and to working together to make our
society more
just as opposed to viewing our opponents
simply as obstacles to the realization
of a just society
so i mean is it safe to say that the
idea and we'll get to
how we best justify this approach but
the idea is that we should
keep acting respectful even in a
complete absence of respect
uh yeah yeah that's that's definitely
one way
one way of putting it i mean one of the
things i was reacting against in turning
to civility was what i saw as a as a
surface
of respect talk um in political
philosophy
and a lot of which was due as as you've
already noted to kant and kind of
neocontian arguments about the
importance of respect
respecting persons respecting
personality and i
think um i'm not i'm not against respect
i suppose i should put that out there
but i think that um it doesn't it's not
adequate for understanding what's going
on with a virtue like civility which is
precisely the one we rely on
in the absence of respect so so far
you're against autonomy you're against
respect i mean this is just a messy
society that you want to
set up this is pretty harsh out there
pretty hobbsian
oh i mean it's i i should say you know
hobbes does
figure in my book and i he's one of my
foils i argue against um
what i take to be the hobbesian view of
civility which is
um what i call civil silence which is
basically
you know no we we can't disagree and so
civility is there to keep us from
you know keep controversial topics off
the table keep us
from saying anything offensive um it
allows us to differ
without disagreeing and i actually think
that that is
the impulse behind a lot of civility
talk today
is we want people to just stop being
disagreeable already
um but uh but i think so you know
i'm against hobsy and civility um as i
understand it
but you're right that my um
my uh affection for
roger williams style mere civility is
based
on a fundamentally kind of hobbesian
view about what
people are like yeah psychologically
both individually and in groups
so just to drive this home really really
hard because i think the people
people do get misled by the nomenclature
a little bit
uh the way that it is used in
many contemporary contexts uh civility
appears as a cudgel there's the dark
side of civility it's actually a
silencing move right like don't talk to
me that way you're not being civil i
don't need to engage with you whereas
you want to bring up the idea of
civility as
continuing to engage no matter how
insulting other people are
and and you know that's the kind of
prerequisite that we need to live in a
pluralistic democracy
that's right i i'm i was struck um
when i was in grad school and when i was
writing the book about just how often
um civility talk was and is used to shut
down debate
um we talk about civility precisely when
we
don't want to make an argument about why
our opponents are wrong instead we want
to say oh well they're uncivil and so i
don't have to engage with them at all
um there's the expression right that um
when we accuse someone of incivility we
place them implicitly
beyond the pale right i mean i i
this expression beyond the pale is
really telling
because it actually comes from the idea
of the pale as um
in latin it comes from the idea of like
a steak but the pale was the fence
around the kind of
city beyond which the barbarians
reside so in dublin for instance you had
the pale of dublin and the barbarous
catholics
were beyond the pale and so i think that
really effectively illustrates kind of
what we're doing
when we say oh well how can i be you
know
so you know so-and-so is being uncivil i
i don't you know i don't
i don't need to engage with engage with
them but what i also point out is that
um
so accusing someone of incivility is a
way of
putting them beyond the pale saying you
know you know
exiling them from the community of
respect
respectable conversationalists but
similarly being uncivil to someone
does the same thing it's sort of it says
you're not worth engaging with in a
civil fashion i can't enjoy
a life with you all i can do is is is
expel you
from the borders and and that
then you know i i don't think we can get
away from that dynamic so i
you know i say suppression and exclusion
are always implicit when we're talking
about civility because we're always
also talking about incivility sort of
talking about where we would draw the
line
but what then needs to happen is we need
to look at different ways of conceiving
of civility
and then see see where the line is drawn
in each case
so in the case of mere civility i think
that's the kind of civility that is
compatible
with the maximally inclusive and
maximally tolerant society that i would
like to live in
there are other ways of conceiving of
civility yeah now the i was going to say
the example of dublin was
worth the entire price of admission to
me like now i know that beyond the pale
is just a reference to barbarous irish
catholics against civilized
anglo-protestants so that that clarifies
a lot a lot to me
but i mean i really do want to
understand this to me
the single biggest difficulty
in trying to come down to figure out
what side i am on in many of these
debates is this issue of
are there people who are beyond the pale
i mean are there people because i think
the answer is yes but i don't know where
to put them but i think there are people
who just
aren't worth engaging with right i mean
you know there are there are
people who disagree with me in maybe a
productive way i mean my
my philosophy of inviting people into
the podcast is i'll
certainly have people i disagree with
but only ones that i think i can get
something from
and there are people who i would never
have on the podcast because my only job
would be like debunk them or make fun of
them and
what is the point of that i think that's
right and
certainly i don't think
that everyone is equally worth
engaging um but by the same token
i don't think that you sean are
proposing to sort of draw the limits of
society as such
based on the limits of whom you would
invite onto your podcast right you sort
of say this is a voluntary association
i'm choosing the people with whom i'm
going to
um debate in this context and what i
worry about
um just generally in public debates
about civility is that
people are sort of indifferent or maybe
insensitive to the ways in which their
own
judgments of who is and is worth not
engaging
are partial and sort of proposing then
to think about civility and tolerance
generally on the basis of their partial
judgments of who
isn't is worth not worth engaging and
there again we go back to just you know
it's it's a feature and a bug this is
how human beings think
it is the case that any person who talks
about civility is implicitly
valorizing themselves as an exemplar
disability this includes me and it also
includes the people i talk about in my
book roger williams thomas hobbes and i
also talk about john locke they're all
sort of implicitly holding themselves
up but only williams i think really
adequately accounts for the fact that
his own judgments are biased and
as i show in the book what that ends up
leading to is is this sort of
seemingly paradoxical but i think it's
not paradoxical
conclusion that civility demands that we
tolerate others in civility right
right so mere civility is is mostly
about
being able and willing to put up
with with others and
you know but once put in that way it
would seem that yes that's the
appropriate way of thinking of civility
in a tolerant society
but now just to go back to your initial
um objection and very good point is
also in a tolerant society i ne and now
then need to be
free to associate in partial
associations
with those i choose right i'm not sort
of committed to
um inviting uh you know uh
my crackpot conspiracy theorist cousin
to my plato reading group right
but i i i am committed to not
saying that he should be sort of
stripped of his rights or or sent to
canada
well yeah i think that's exactly and
it's a good distinction that you
drew because i was a little vague and
saying you know some people are not
worth talking to
uh that depends a lot on the context in
which we're defining talking to
right so on twitter i'm really good at
blocking
people like i have no patience for
putting up with people who are just
there to cause trouble
but i don't want those people to be
denied the right to vote in my society
right like i don't want to voluntarily
chat with them but i think that they
have a
full right to have their voice heard in
the polity and
that seems to be uh an important
distinction but
still it's still hard because there are
some people who maybe shouldn't have the
right to vote i don't know but uh
where to draw that line so i was
thinking more personally
than politically when i said you know
where do we draw the line between people
where
we feel are worth engaging with and
people we just want to ignore
i think i mean and just being becoming
aware that those are two different lines
i think is really sort of more than half
the battle i think that um the twitter
example is really good there because
twitter and other sort of social media
are
really do occupy this kind of ambiguous
space an ambiguous space
in american law and also an ambiguous
case uh
space just in in in in our minds i mean
we refer to them quaintly as platforms
um which is the traditional medium of
amplifying the
the spoken word um but they also
function as presses right as publishing
so when we when i tweet it's it's like
i'm publishing my view
and putting it out there then to be
debated and increasingly
these uh these platforms
become approximations of the public
sphere
but on the other hand they're also
private
um private companies but also private
associations right i mean twitter can
expel and de-platform those who violated
its terms and conditions right and so i
think that
the fact that so much of the debate is
happening about speech
on these platforms um
just contributes to the further
confusion
of um you know
what the limit is which what kind of
limit is appropriate for different kinds
of uh
fora and it sort of invites us to
conflate
the limit of our you know twitter uh
twitter association with the limit of
sort of you know tolerable views to be
expressed in american society or british
society et cetera as such
i mean the other thing that social media
platforms do and it's something that i
come up against and i imagine you do too
is that they're transnational in a way
that's great
but also can be highly misleading so um
a lot of time i mean it really has come
it has uh just further
um uh exacerbated this this cultural
tendency to export
all american culture wars to the world
i feel bad for the rest of the world yes
yeah
but also it's just it it brings us up
against the fact that civility
is always necessarily a kind of local
standard
right the standard of civility in
american discourse is going to be
different from the standard of civility
in british discourse but a
forum like twitter doesn't allow us to
actually
um distinguish between those audiences
and so that's why also there are all
so many um uh uh conflicts and
disruptions and sort of moments where
competing codes of civility clash um
and that can also lead to this
increasing sense of um a kind of crisis
of civility
uh because we are you know we just we
have these amazing megaphones now that
allow us to address
audiences we could never even have
dreamed yeah of
when we often feel like oh you know i'm
just complaining to my friends
well just to bring this down to sort of
real world um conflicts here so
for example consider the idea of
de-platforming speakers at a university
right
um there's some people have an idea that
uh if one group at my university wants
to invite a speaker
even though i'm not a member of that
group and i don't have anything to do
with them i don't like them i don't
agree with them
i still you know there's some right i'm
putting words into their mouth because i
don't
feel this way myself so i'm probably not
making the best case for it but
there's some uh justification for me
trying to shut them down right i presume
that uh going along with the civility
discourse
uh you would be against that kind of
shutting down i think it
i i think it's complicated i i mean not
to bury the lead
yes i i am concerned about um
no platforming and d platforming and
kind of this rising tide of demands
to deep platform at universities
however i do think that universities
are importantly distinct from society at
large
so i do think that universities um i
mean of course this is different
um in the united states when it comes to
public universities which are covered by
the first amendment
um but in private universities yeah i
mean you can suppress and exclude people
on the basis of their speech for the
speech that they that you think that
they might make
that's fine you have the right to do
that now the question is
should you do that um and there
i think that it is it's a complicated
question
but we should we should tend towards no
and the reason we should tend towards no
is because
not because we're going to violate the
free speech rights of the speaker
so let's take the case of i don't know i
mean there are lots of um
controversy over uh on campus talks
given by charles murray
a couple years ago it's not because i'm
worried about charles murray's
charles murray's free speech rights
being infringed i'm worried about the
infringement of the free speech rights
of the students who invite him
right so they're right to sort of hear
his argument now
by the way i think it's interesting to
think of the the right to listen to
somebody as an aspect of free speech
yeah and again it goes back to isagria i
mean i think that
universities are sites or you should
aspire to be sites
of isagoria um you know but uh sort of
within their remit as educational
institutions i.e so i'm not saying that
you know that means
students are equal speakers on a par
with their professors when it comes to
matters of academic expertise
however you know i do think a seminar is
one of those places where we're trying
to realize the kind of
ideal of equal speech where everyone has
a voice and feels able to
uh get a hearing yeah right and so i do
think that um events like public talks
on campus or private talks on campus
are precisely places where we're
training students not only in speaking
but in listening and responding then
to views that they don't hold i mean so
the the but i do think i mean so the
proponents of no or d platforming
have a case the case is that in
providing a controversial speaker like
murray or
um whoever a platform we're
sort of uh endorsing in some way or
elevating uh the content of their views
and that in a way that can cause harm or
in some way threaten
the equal standing of members of our
community
i think there are cases where certain
speakers
should not be invited to campus well i
think it's important to me to draw the
distinction between
uh if someone is invited by the
university
to see you know give a university
sponsored talk uh
or you know receive an honorary degree
or something then
i have no problem with members of the
university community
uh protesting that and trying to stop it
where was what i was imagining like
some little subgroup of the university
you know the college racist association
wants to invite charles murray uh then
even if i think that racism is bad i
think that i should let them do that
yeah and i mean i i'm inclined to make
the same distinction i do think there's
a clear distinction between inviting
someone to give a commencement address
and allowing the college republicans to
invite whoever they'd like
or the you know the the um the
you know the local um boycott divest and
sanction
you know movement to invite whoever
they'd like um i do think however that
universities
there is a role for virtuous uh
university administrators in this case
wait what
um that you know to uh
help guide student associations to
um act responsibly in extending
invitations
um to sort of not
encourage this kind of fu
approach sometimes i think to students
inviting speakers to campus
um and also to engage in you know
crowd management and determining sort of
what's the appropriate
venue for a speaker etc you know i
i think we often wanted to turn these
cases into hard and fast sort of
conflicts over principle when in fact
you know actually maybe the principle
isn't so controversial
it's the question of the particular
policies or prudential judgments about
how we're going to organize a specific
event
um but yeah i'm inclined to agree with
you and i guess you know in terms of um
is there a kind of cultural problem um
growing in american campuses
i would be less inclined to look at
particular cases where student
associations have invited a
controversial speaker
and more to look at cases where uh
university administrators have been
pressured into rescinding
invitations to um you know uh
speakers to give commencement addresses
or to receive honorary doctorates
and those sort of incidents uh have been
on the rise in recent years as well but
they don't tend to be as headline
grabbing
um uh for instance what happened at
middlebury with charles murray
well i mean there certainly is a
tendency or at least a temptation
uh you know students bless their hearts
i was a student once over you
you know that students like to
stir things up a little bit and
sometimes they'll invite
people just to be provocative but
putting that aside i mean
talk about the extent to which there is
a positive virtue
in seeking out opposing views i mean is
that part of the civility
uh paradigm or is it just we should
tolerate these
uh these noisy people we disagree with
but i think that john stewart mill would
probably make the case that we should
actually
make an effort to go listen to them how
does that fit into
uh your slightly different point of view
so there's a positive case as well i
mean
whereas mill emphasizes the importance
of listening to
contrary views so as to strengthen one's
own
argument i mean he has that great line
and on liberty uh he who
knows only his own side of a case knows
little of that yeah
um which i always love i love drawing
students attention to but um
as ever you know in my in my preference
for 17th century evangelicals
in their approach to this uh it's more
an emphasis on you know there's little
point
it seems to me in discoursing
exclusively with people who agree with
you already
uh one reason for that is that you know
there's little point in that if you
don't already know what you think
which hopefully you know i think most
students don't i think most adults
don't i'm very willing to admit that
there are plenty of controversial topics
on which people
seem to have very strong views but i
have no idea what i think and i think
that's perfectly appropriate
um so so there's that consideration but
also
on the topics in which i do have strong
views surely i should want to persuade
others that i'm right and they're wrong
rather than just having all of those
wonderful backslapping conversations
with those people who already agree with
me about how very wrong those people we
never talk to are
um so for me i just it seems like what
is the point of
talk i guess we always come back to that
why why bother talking to each other in
the first place and i
think that there is something missing in
the million account um
about that kind of evangelical impulse
the the impulse to persuade
um and to try to bring others around to
our way of thinking
well it also shows up there's a
political aspect to this where
um purity comes in right and and i see
online
you know online is not an accurate
reflection of the world but
there are people who would argue that
you know their favorite candidate
shouldn't want the support of certain
groups
because those groups are bad or they're
insufficiently good and
my thought is if i'm a political
candidate i want everyone literally
everybody to vote for me i want the
worst people in the world to vote for me
that doesn't mean i endorse their views
but i'm happy to take their support
as a political theorist i i do again
wonder uh often about people's
understanding of how
democracy works and the importance of
coalition building
um i mean so that that's glib but
there's a serious point there i mean yes
we we want
to win elections yeah
right of elections to win um
are you sure it's not to demonstrate our
purity because i've
i've gotten the impression and then we
do we come to this really sort of
perverse state of affairs where actually
the point of an election is to lose but
to lose for the right
right um and i just i i
i find that difficult to square then
with
the sort of criterion upon which we are
the criteria upon which we're demanding
purity i.e
our vision of a just society and surely
if we want to make a society more
just we've got to win the election um
in order to do so i think you're right i
mean there is uh
again you know if we think about the
advantages of the long
view uh you know puritanism kind of
became a bad
word or sort of a you know puritan is a
kind of pejorative
um in contemporary politics uh
but of course i study 17th century
puritans and i see all the virtues
appear so to sort of call something
puritan isn't isn't uh
isn't to criticize it in my view um
but i do think you know studying
puritanism and the kind of drive for
purity within political and social and
spiritual movements
um you can see its benefits and you can
also see its um
its uh disadvantages quite clearly
and you know i would just say that um
another reason i like williams maybe
maybe you know williams was a puritan
but he was so puritan
that he realized that everybody else was
going to hell yeah which meant that
he had to compromise with those people
who were going to hell
in order to be able to get anything done
you know he has this wonderful line
one must go out of the world if one
would not keep company with idolaters
right so you know insofar as we're stuck
in this world
we've really got to make the best of it
and do the good we can and we can't do
that good
without other people well that's what
makes him so interesting because he
he did somehow manage to be a successful
political leader
despite these strong uh philosophical
views
that's a controversial statement often
times people come back to me and they
say you know
rhode island wasn't a success okay well
what's your criterion of success i mean
rhode island was the last colony to
ratify the constitution
you're saying that like it's a bad thing
um but yeah i just say you know the
thing about we we don't tend to think of
rhode island when we're thinking about
you know
uh early modern societies to hold up as
exemplars but um
that being said i mean it was at the
time and for a long time the most
tolerant society in the world it was the
only society to my knowledge without you
know in
in the in certainly in the world of
western christendom but also beyond
without an established church
i mean that's bananas yeah uh you know
very very often williams is linked with
john locke as though you know williams
just made locks arguments 50 years
earlier and with a bunch of
unnecessary scriptural quotations but um
but there's a really important
difference in that williams
argued that tolerance required that
there not be an established church
locke was okay with establishment so
long as church attendance wasn't
mandatory wasn't mandatory um
so i think these kinds of differences
which from one perspective are kind of
oh well these are small distinctions
that are maybe of interest to historians
i would actually say no they're actually
quite significant and understanding
those distinctions
in sort of historical context can help
us make sense of some of the kind of
confounding
uh factors to the you know to to
our attempts to put our principles into
practice today
i mean the only other thing just to say
on the um the point about moral purity
and politics today
i mean if we're worried about free
speech the principle of free speech
as a means to just further entrenching
the status quo i mean
nothing is better for the status quo
than puritanism and politics
if we're so worried about having only
the right people on our side we can be
we can absolutely be assured that things
will continue to go as they are
well you know i have to say even taking
into account your affection for
17th century evangelicals i was
impressed
by your ability to link the quakers with
contemporary debates over the use of
pronouns to uh talk about
different gender identities
you have to share that with uh with our
audience and it maybe will lead us into
a little bit of talk about
uh the the connection between freedom of
speech and civility and equality which
is a whole another bag of worms
oh brilliant yeah and that equality is
my my current uh hobby horse
so uh it's very much on my mind um
so i i mean as you mentioned i
wrote this article um that was uh
it was published in by the new york
times uh editorial page about
uh the politics of pronouns using early
quakers as an example
as one does um yeah as one does well as
a group that was really concerned about
the ways in which the rules of grammar
uh stood in the way of an egalitarian
society and so you know it sounds funny
but it's actually really there's a
really serious point i mean much like
contemporary um trans and genderqueer
activists who um
you know are arguing for the importance
of gender-neutral pronouns quakers
thought
that um the the english second person
uh pronoun you
was actually um
uh a form of and again because we're
talking the 17th century i'm going to
use their terms
but a form of idolatry or uh
devil worship so the reason for this
which is not
immediately obvious to modern speakers
of english is because you is actually
the plural um in early modern english
there was a singular second person
pronoun which was v
and a plural second person pronoun which
was you and so in the 17th century
around the time that the quakers are
becoming active you're seeing this
change in english grammar where the is
basically being crowded out by you
everybody is beginning to use the second
person plural
and quakers like george fox um
william penn saw this as
um basically a as
a demand for everyone to have a kind of
elevated status
much like the queen refers to herself as
herself as weak exactly
right the royal we everybody is now
demanding that they be acknowledged as
you
and obviously this sounds weird for
english speakers but anyone who knows a
romance language or or
um or german or any other uh language
that has a distinction between the
plural and the singular
um where this where the plural you is
used in cases of of deference
will understand the kind of politics
here and so um
quakers uh instead of just putting up or
in shutting up they decided to wage a
campaign
against the plural you and so the
quakers insisted on using
um singular pronouns so v and thou
with not just other quakers but with
everyone
and so if you look at the early
reception of quakerism which was far
from welcoming
um one of the one of the main things
that really pissed people off at the
time is that they
they object to the quaker use of v as a
form of insult or contempt
as i mean it wouldn't be a stretch to
say to 17th century english speakers to
be called the
by a quaker was a kind of hate speech it
sounds completely bizarre
to modern ears because we because it's
archaic we think of the endow as somehow
more formal but they were
exactly the opposite they were the sort
of familiar uh
casual way of talking absolutely uh
and so roger williams who i've been
extolling for the past hour for his
extraordinary tolerance i mean the one
group to really test his patience
was the quakers um and it was precisely
because he thought that their use
of the and now expressed contempt um and
i guess it you know it was
a contempt he didn't like because he was
perfectly fine with repressing contempt
in other ways
but there was a real worry about the
quakers unwillingness
to kind of just go with the flow and to
abide by
the culturally contingent norms of
respectful behavior right so the quakers
unwillingness to be
merely civil uh so that's where you know
these two stories
connect once more um but anyway so i i
was just really interested in trying to
parse
the the egalitarian politics of quaker
pronouns and in the article i i contrast
that actually with contemporary
activists
because um from the quakers perspective
what trans activists want um
or those who speak for them maybe i you
know it's more
correct to say with uh gender neutral
pronouns is basically
is the right for everyone to be able to
choose their own pronoun
and for the quakers that wouldn't be a
kind of
claim to equality at all it would
actually be a kind of claim to
distinction
yeah right it'd be a way of saying well
everyone's entitled to pick
their own title um and so the quaker
view isn't said that equality demands
that everybody
just be you know treated as contemptible
and sort of
leveled down right we might distinguish
here between leveling up
versions of equality where everyone's
treated as an aristocrat and leveling
down versions where everyone's treated
as a commoner
and uh the quakers are firmly in the
leveling down camp
um and so that that that comparison i
think is is
is a helpful one for seeing um you know
here's a contemporary issue
that's really controversial
tempers and tensions run high on this
question of gender-neutral pronouns
but if we consider it with historical
perspective we can actually see well
here is a conflict not about whether or
not we care about equality
but rather about what equality demands
of us in our interactions and i think
that's really helpful
yeah um for kind of reframing
this controversial topic in such a way
that people can actually see okay well
maybe
people on the other side have a point i
don't have to agree with it but they
have a point
and in recognizing they have a point i
can therefore engage
well okay so uh what's the right answer
um well i'm in the process of writing
this
this new book uh which is tentatively
entitled
first among equals and it's about the
the theory and practice of equality
in the 17th century and and what that
you know what that can help us
understand about um uh the theory and
practice of equality today
but uh i suppose one answer is that
egalitarian politics is ever a mixture
of leveling up and leveling down and
attempts to focus
exclusively on one poll uh
will fail um because they're both really
important
um the second answer is that as ever
there's a cultural difference um
and here i'm really inspired by work um
by james q whitman
on um who's a legal historian
um uh yale and he he's written a book
called harsh justice which was really
interested in why the american justice
system is so much um
more brutal than than european
uh systems and and systems of punishment
and
jim's answer is that well look i mean
american equality was always about
treating everyone equally badly
whereas in in europe in these formerly
aristocratic societies
equality became a business of bringing
everyone up to the level
of aristocrats the best example of this
is the use of the guillotine
in the french revolution because
beheading
was the form of capital punishment
reserved for aristocrats
whereas commoners would be hanged right
so the french revolution
was an egalitarian movement and one of
the ways that this manifested was by
saying well no everybody gets to have
their head cut off
okay yes that's the leveling down i
suppose
no no that's leveling up i'm sorry he's
leveling up yeah
the procrustean bed of leveling up um
everywhere in the american case you know
all
criminals could be subjected to corporal
punishment um and that was to treat them
as
as slaves so anyway so i
i'm interested too in kind of
differences of cultures
that we might describe as broadly
egalitarian and then sort of
how that issues and kind of social and
cultural norms
um but i'm also i guess the main upshot
of my work on equality at the
at the moment is i is that
um i think that equality is perhaps
less important normatively than
we tend to think it is um in
contemporary politics and so a lot of
times uh
that when people are talking about
equality i think they're actually not so
concerned about equality they're
concerned about other things
uh and so one of the things i'd like to
do in sort of thinking more about
equality is try
to parse you know what is it that we're
actually sort of talking about when
we're talking about equality
um well this was actually what i wanted
to ask you about this because
it's not clear to me whether we should
be thinking about i mean
maybe this goes back to milton versus
mill again is
equality something that we should take
as a metaphysical principle the people
are created equal
or is it just the most convenient
pragmatic way
to act in a democracy right you know to
sort of give people equal
um uh claim on various uh rights and
resources even though
we don't actually think of them as equal
to us
yeah so you can talk about the
difference between mil and milton but
you also think
we might also think about the difference
between hobbes and kant again i mean for
hobbes
the idea that people are equal is
essentially a pragmatic belief
so we agree to treat others
as though they were our equals even
though they are in fact
not equal yeah um because that's what
makes
a stable and peaceful society possible
as opposed to the kind of kantian view
which says that well
um treating people with equal dignity
is a reflection of their basic equality
um that it you know it's fundamentally
grounded and kind of facts about us
um as moral persons and i guess
my own view i mean this won't surprise
you based on the
discussion we've been having is i do
incline to the hobbesian view
um that human beings are not in fact
equal along any of the dimensions that
we might point to
although they're you know there are
long-standing debates in moral and
political philosophy about how we
how we should understand that claim um
and you know it's
it's a complicated issue um but that
we are the more pressing political
concern
is you know how
what what should a society that resolves
to treat people as equals look like
right so what's demanded um
you know uh but that that sort of view
that says that you know it's less
important to justify basic equality than
it is to actually think about what you
know what
what treating people as equals means um
would be strongly
uh objected to you by someone like
jeremy waldron who would say that
no you know that amounts to just sort of
arbitrarily saying that you know people
are equal because we say so and that's a
very sort of weak grounding
for something so important so you know
i'm very i'm very
sensitive to and i take seriously um
the other side but i guess one thing
that becomes really clear again when we
treat these questions historically is
that
you know the the belief or the dogma
that human beings are
somehow equal by nature
isn't actually that important for
egalitarian politics and you know i say
that because
we tend to think about natural equality
as something that was discovered or
invented
um in the 17th century or kind of
thereabouts you know suddenly everybody
realized oh
right we were created equal and this has
consequences and you know we better get
on that
you know it's just not what happened at
all i mean the idea that human beings
were equal by nature
was a philosophical and a theological
commonplace
for millennia um it just wasn't seen as
having social and political consequences
and so the interesting question for me
is why suddenly you know in and around
the 17th century
does this idea of natural equality
equality suddenly
begin to have consequences that we might
recognize as egalitarian
um and i you know
i just i i'm really interested to sort
of unpick
the just so historical stories that so
often
inform a lot of the moral and political
philosophical discussion of basic
equality
um you know that assumes that oh well
modernity is defined by its commitment
to natural equality in a way that like
you know pre-modernity wasn't and it's
just that's just factually
wrong right um and so you know i think
there's a benefit that comes from
correcting the record um
in any case well i mean maybe maybe to
to close here we can bring it
to uh back up to the present day you
know having having enjoyed the 17th
century in similar debates for a while
so
i'm trying to you know take what you've
said about civility
uh and free speech and put it in the
context of the contemporary debate over
cancel culture for example right i mean
if i think of just to take one very
specific example
jk rowling has gotten a lot of pushback
for saying things
that are interpreted in certain circles
as being anti-trans
anti-transgender people and on the one
hand
you could say well jk rowling has the
right to say whatever she wants you know
that
has nothing to do with you buying her
books or anything like that she has the
right to
to say all these things on the other
hand you can say well all these people
have the right to
criticize her and ask other people not
to buy her books and
sort of is that actually a happy medium
or is there some decline of western
civilization going on here because
jk rowling cannot tweet about what she
wants
uh yes this signals the decline of
western civilization like
no other event yeah it is i mean
it is funny right there is this tendency
to treat the latest crisis as though you
know oh this is totally unprecedented
and this
finally is like that last nail in the
veil in the coffin
um yeah i mean the current debate about
cancel culture
uh on the one hand i i
agree with critics who say oh you know
worries about canceled culture overblown
um jk ojk rowling is hardly at risk of
being
of being silenced because she has the
power prestige privilege etc where she
can actually speak out
um and so you know i i am uh you know
sensitive to that i don't think that
people saying mean things to jk rowling
on twitter is somehow the most pressing
kind of social justice issue of our time
um however right and then there's the
big however
i do think that there is a kind of
cultural problem i don't think it's
recent
um i think it's been coming on for ages
it's very much implicit in the kind of
you know the stuff that i was writing
about civility in
in the 2010s um and earlier
and it's this sort of intolerance
for um
views or the people who happen to hold
those views that we consider to be
intolerable
and i do think that there is this kind
of
push to redefine the meaning of
tolerance to
something more like a tolerant society
is one wherein everybody accepts and
includes
everybody else um and for reasons we've
already discussed i just don't think
that can fly i think that might be an
accepting society um but an accepting
society isn't a tolerant one
um and i was you know
bemused by a lot of the pushback uh
against
rowling and against the the harper's
letter which she signed and another sign
sort of saying oh well you know one
there is no such thing as cancel culture
which was one response
two if there is cancel culture it is in
no way infringing
the freedom of speech of the people who
are complaining about it
and three if it is infringing the
freedom of speech with those complaining
about it well that's a good thing
right so obviously these three responses
are not themselves
compatible
we're saying all three um but
i do yeah i just think well yes of
course there's a concern about freedom
of speech there it's a concern about a
culture
turning against parisia and of course
it's the people who are most powerful
within that system people who have a
huge platform like rowling who feel able
to speak out against it
right and so my concern is those who
don't share that power who don't share
that privilege and who nevertheless
see what happens to someone love someone
like rowling or you know it's
or you know or pick whomever your sort
of um sacrificial lamb of the moment
is uh see what happens when someone says
something that um
others object to and conclude uh quite
rightly that it's not worth taking the
risk
for themselves and you know and i
approach these issues again from the
perspective of someone trying to
teach young people to think
and argue and disagree with each other
and i see it in my students this sort of
we do a free speech unit and this sort
of
unwillingness uh even in that seminar
discussion right which of course was
taking place on zoom because you know
this is this is the end of time
is unwillingness to sort of you know say
things that they were afraid their peers
would think of as being sort of uh
you know uh unacceptable and already you
know we we already
sort of are are so sensitive to what
other people think of us
of course this kind of culture
will have will have a chilling effect
and of course
you know jk rowling uh deciding to sue
someone for libel will have a chilling
effect and
you know my my wish would be just that
you know people remembered
that freedom of speech was more was
about more than simply legal rights
yeah before before things got so out of
hand
um i mean i guess i i i again i'm
broadly sympathetic to everything you're
saying here
but to sort of channel the the concerns
that immediately pop
up i mean there i mean we haven't gotten
this on the table yet so it's important
to get it that
the people who complain about jk rowling
um are not necessarily saying look i
have an intellectual disagreement with
you they're saying
look i am a member of a group that uh
is underpowered discriminated against
silenced in society and you are denying
my right to exist
and so they would they would say this is
this is
beyond the pale this is this is
something that i can object to this kind
of speech existing not just to the
the content of what you're saying
so that is that is very much um
the case that's made and again i take
seriously the claim there which i see as
a claim to isagria
um but i come back to sort of what
should be given priority
in the public sphere of a tolerant
society
and to me the priority has to go to
parisia precisely because
my commitment to allowing
jk rowling to speak her mind is not
because i value the contents of her mind
it's because i value the contents of of
the minds of those people who haven't
hitherto had a voice and i do i mean
you're right to push me on this because
i do
simply reject and do so seriously and i
hope respectfully but i do
i do reject the claim that anything that
jk rowling might say about trans women
denies their right to exist okay
you know i think that you might say okay
there are certain speech acts
i can engage i i can i can utter
the phrase trans women don't have the
right to exist
right but even my uttering that precise
phrase would not deny them the right to
exist precisely because
my speech isn't authoritative right
in that way and it's not authoritative
precisely because
we live in a society wherein no one
person's speech has given that authority
and i think here you know we come
specifically to the issue about rowling
which
has to do with the powerful position she
occupies
um as a kind of venerated figure among
young people many of whom feel
themselves to be outsiders and outcasts
because
of uh being the creator of the harry
potter universe
and there i would just say well the
right thing to do then
is um or one thing to do and i think a
good thing to do
is take advantage of the wonderful um
invention that is fan fiction and do
what you will with her characters
yeah right you know claim it for
yourself and use your own voice
i i just i i i do um
again i spent a lot of time as someone
who kind of you know grew up being
a sort of free speech fundamentalist not
thinking very deeply about these issues
at all
i've learned so much by
reading and engaging with the arguments
of people who
who criticize that view and so i would
say that you know i've become much more
reflective in the holding of my views
but what i do see in the debate about
free speech
and cancel culture on the internet and
right in this specific moment
is a lot of trans women speaking up for
themselves
yes but i also see a lot of
cisgendered usually white usually
men people speaking up on behalf
of those they take to be disenfranchised
or marginalized
and i would just sort of really
encourage everybody
to reflect really hard on when we
claim to be speaking for someone else um
because again it goes back to my
to my point which is that individuals
you know identities don't speak
individuals do um and so
yes i think many trans women are
justifiably hurt or
upset frustrated and aggrieved by things
that jk rowling has said
but i would say that you know not all
trans women
are and that should be the discussion
we're having i mean this reification
of of gender and racial identities in
this moment again i think is politically
necessary sometimes
but shouldn't itself be the end goal and
maybe maybe the point to end on is
actually
um something that was was there and what
you said earlier about civility that
the challenge to the listener right the
the fact that being this kind of
participant in a democratic
wild and wooly uh civil disagreement
kind of society
uh is tough it means we're gonna have to
hear things we don't like and it's our
responsibility to sort of
uh deal with that in
some way other than silencing and i
would just you know i acknowledge
that the burdens of that dealing with or
the burdens of putting up with
unpleasant uncivil or even hateful
speech
are unequally distributed that's
absolutely right it's the members of
racial minorities gender minorities
um other disaffected other alienated
marginalized groups
are called upon to tolerate more
and i sort of take that as given and i
take that as undesirable and i think it
is in many ways
unjust recognizing that fact
though is not itself then a sort of
refutation over denial of the importance
of free speech or
saying that an alternative system would
be better would
distribute the burdens more equally it
might
but i again i think that we have a lot
of historical data to suggest that it
would not
right and so the question then is well
how can we make the best of the system
that we have
and i think that the answer there has to
do with the cultural institutions it has
to do with associational freedom
and yes it has to do with a culture of
speaking one's mind and of developing
the virtues that allow us to do that in
an engaged way but also to listen
in return and you know just sort of
remind
readers and listeners i mean you know
what people said at the time of roger
williams rhode island they called it
rogues island they called it the latrine
of new england
nobody not even roger williams thought
that this was a precise a
pretty uh you know a particularly nice
place to live
right but the business of toleration
isn't pretty
um it's difficult and it requires the
managing of things that will
that are and will remain disagreeable
and there is this sort of orientation
not just in politics generally but in
political theory and political
philosophy specifically which seems to
say well you know some of these problems
can be
transcended or dissolved and i just
think that that's
that's not right some of these problems
are permanent and we just have to rub
along
and sort of make the best of it the
business of toleration is not pretty i
like that that's a very good
motto to end on and you know what's
important here is that now we know what
side you're on so we've we've
[Laughter]
[Music]
just well you know i suppose um
is this like is it the groucho marx line
you know i would never be a club i'd
never be a member of a club that would
have me as a member
the second the second that uh that i
i find myself on a side is the second i
have to think really hard
and uh and and reconsider my position so
i just you know i'm lucky enough to have
the have the job and position
um that i do that allows me to do that
and i and i don't take it for granted
it's something to aspire to so theresa
bijan thanks so much for being on the
mindscape podcast
thank you very much for having me we
really really enjoyed it
[Music]
you